[Música]
en el momento de hablar de economía aquí
en directo américa para ello está
conmigo en el estudio daniela blandón
daniela bienvenida feliz lunes para ti
bienvenida de nuevo a este espacio
matinal vamos a hablar de nicaragua
porque los ojos no sólo están puesto una
política sino también daniela en la
economía o la raúl buenos días qué bueno
estar otra vez acá con un cincuentón
pues mire ya sabemos que el consejo
supremo electoral dio por ganador a
daniel ortega a través de las elecciones
pero la permanencia de ortega raúl puede
tener varias consecuencias en el plano
económico vinculadas especialmente con
su relación con grandes potencias como
eeuu o la unión europea que no reconocen
la transparencia de estos comicios ya
eeuu raúl tienen listas nuevas sanciones
y la administración de joe biden está
revisando la participación del país en
un tratado de libre comercio
centroamericano que hoy en día otorga
trato preferencial a las importaciones
que recibe desde allí y es que
recordemos que eeuu es su principal
socio comercial
así ingeniero pero para entender un poco
el contexto mejor hagamos un repaso de
la economía de ese país bueno pues
llegará quién llegará al poder de todas
maneras y va a tener grandes retos
económicos raúl el producto interno
bruto de ese país se ha contraído un 88
por ciento acumulado entre 2018 y 2020
antes venía a decrecer un 3,9 por ciento
acumulado en promedio anual el desempleo
desde alrededor del 5 por ciento pero el
problema más grave es la informalidad
que afecta a entre 6 y 7 habitantes de
cada diez y uno de los principales
problemas también es que nicaragua ya se
quedó sin capacidad de endeudamiento su
deuda externa es de 12 mil millones de
dólares y eso es más del 95 por ciento
del pib bueno y dejamos un lado entonces
nicaragua para hablar de la cob 26
porque unos países si se comprometieron
a dejar de usar el carbón pero otros
simplemente no quisieron que mal ejemplo
claro raúl y es que bueno fueron 46
países que firmaron en glasgow esta
declaración para dejar de usar
gradualmente el carbón a lo largo del
tiempo pero entre los firmantes no están
los países que más usan carbón que son
estados unidos australia china
el ministro australiano de recursos que
es dijo en declaraciones a la red
nacional de noticias abc que no van a
generar o que no van a cerrar mejor las
minas de carbón y que tampoco van a
cerrar las plantas que producen
electricidad con base en este recurso
pues el carbón australiano es uno de los
de mayor calidad pues en sydney hubo
protestas el fin de semana porque
contrario a lo que otros países están
intentando este si planea que la demanda
de carbón crezca hasta 2030 ya que es
uno de los mayores productores y también
una de las principales víctimas del
cambio climático raúl porque tiene
sequías inundaciones e incendios
forestales constantemente terrible
daniela pero cambiamos ahora nuevamente
información y le pregunto cuál es la
nueva excentricidad del dueño de texas
la buena gusta él sabe que cada vez que
y lo más que publica un tweet puede ser
un terremoto o puede ser que todo el
mundo celebre en wall street y por qué
porque es el hombre más rico del mundo
después de ya superó tengamos al dueño
de amazon y pues bueno la muestra está
en este nuevo trío es una encuesta en la
que pregunta a los internautas si están
de acuerdo o no con que él venda el 10
por ciento de la participación que tiene
en tesla o sea unos 21.000 millones de
dólares la encuesta tuvo 35 millones de
votos y el 57,9 por ciento dijo que si
pagamos una comparación 28 millones de
personas votaron en las elecciones de
nicaragua y 3.5 mil pesos así que pues
bueno la influencia de esta de estos
influenciadores mejor dicho bueno ahí
está en juego de palabras daniela porque
se dice que el lemos que va de impuestos
mire de raúl se dice que y los nuevos
que aumenta cada vez más su fortuna
porque el valor de la fabricante de
autos de lujo se ha disparado en la
pandemia de hecho su valor en bolsa ya
superó el billón de dólares millones de
millones pero ese dinero no entra
directamente al bolsillo del empresario
a no ser de que venda las acciones por
lo tanto no tributan y como él no
percibe un sueldo de ninguna clase la
única forma de pagar impuestos dice él
es vendiendo acciones indicadores
económicos hablando de acciones daniela
bueno las acciones se mueven éstas raúl
al ritmo de eeuu que va a presentar su
informe de inflación en asia las bolsas
cayeron pendientes también del grande
evergrande al que se le venció un nuevo
plazo de intereses valga la redundancia
con grande eveland en europa las bolsas
operan mixtas esperando la apertura de
wall street por supuesto y por afinar
para finalizar este primer bloque de
economía le preguntó por la cifra del
día nos vamos para china porque las
exportaciones crecieron un 27 1% en
octubre de este año interanual quiere
decir frente al mismo mes del año pasado
daniela y nos vamos directo hasta
glasgow ahí no está esperando nuestra
enviada especial marina colorado vámonos
a unos para glasgow